can we really get to educational choice
because a lot of these parents can't
afford to send their kids somewhere else
can we really get to that real education
choice given the current state of
collective bargaining in this
commonwealth and in this country to a
large degree yeah absolutely i'm going
to say something that's incredibly
unpopular with this group and that's
totally fine
the best education in the world
currently takes place in finland they
have the top education model and
they have completely banned private
education i would do the same
okay so
uh first of all finland is not the
united states and there there's a
frequent attempt uh that it does happen
a lot where people will take something
that has worked in sweden or something
that's worked in norway or something
that's worked in finland they'll say
what if we just take that import it here
and it'll work exactly the same way and
it typically does not work the fact is
that that finnish americans make more
money in the united states than they do
in finland for example they have longer
life expectancies in the united states
than they do in finland that's true
swedish americans it's true for nordic
life expectancy in finland is much
higher than the united states no you're
correct hold on at least 78 no
by the way
hold on a second you're correct the life
expectancy in finland is longer than
life expectancy in the united states
that's not what i said i said the life
expectancy for finnish americans is
longer in the united states that is an
apples-to-apples comparison as opposed
to comparing completely different
populations and that's kind of my point
okay the fact is that the united states
has an incredibly diverse population and
that diverse population encompasses an
enormous number of people who have very
different beliefs about how education
ought to be done to suggest that any
national standard of education is going
to not only please all of those people
but prove to be successful in such a
wide variety of circumstances for some
330 million people we've tried this with
a gradual not gradually radically
increasing federal education budget over
the course of the last 30 years and what
we've got is failing public schools all
over the united states except in
specific local areas where there have
been attempts to take back control
locally i'd love to see more locale more
localization and frankly i'm quite
pleased that if covett had one decent
effect it was more people taking their
kids out of the public schools